now then Scotland's first Minister and
the SNP leader Nicholas sturgeon has
described the actions of an MP Margaret
fer as utterly indefensible after she
admitted the MP admitted breaking coid
rules in the last few minutes M sturgeon
tweeted that this is utterly
indefensible it's hard to express just
how angry I feel on behalf of people
across the country making hard
sacrifices every day to help beat coid
the rules apply to everyone and they're
in place to keep people safe uh and Ian
Blackford MP who's the snp's leader in
the House of Commons in Westminster is
right to suspend the wh that from um the
S&P overall leader Nicholas sturon first
minister of Scotland and our chief
political correspondent John Craig is
here with me now just better to explain
to people who who aren't fully across
what what's happened here is what
Margaret fer did amongst other things
she tested positive while in London
attending the house of common she tested
positive uh for coid 19 and then
traveled on a train from from London to
Scotland she traveled on the train
before she got the results of the test
what happened it's just a spectacular
breach of the rules in a number of ways
let me just read what uh but Margaret
fer has said she is the MP for uh rather
Glenn and Hamilton West in Scotland uh
and she said in a statement tonight I
apologize unreservedly for breaching
coid 19 restrictions by traveling this
week when I shouldn't have there's no
excuse for my actions she says on
Saturday afternoon after experiencing
mild symptoms I requested a coid test
which I took that day Saturday feeling
much better I then traveled to London by
train on Monday to attend Parliament as
planned this was wrong and I'm very
sorry for my mistake on Monday evening I
received a positive test result for coid
19 I traveled home by train on Tuesday
morning without seeking advice this was
also wrong and I'm sorry I've been
self-isolating at home ever since well
she didn't just attend Parliament she
spoke on Monday evening either just
before or just after she got the
positive test result she spoke in the
Commons debate on Monday night on
coid I'd like to start by paying tribute
to all NHS keyw workers and volunteers
and my constituency for their care and
commitment over the last seven months
I'm going to focus my comments the
economic yeah I mean I just wanted to
say she also did she not criticize in in
the past criticize uh Dominic Cummings
bis Johnson's advisor back in back in
late may she hit Out Mr Cummings said
his actions have undermined the
sacrifices we all been making in
lockdown to protect others his position
is untenable he must be removed from his
post now remember that was after Mr
Cummings drove to Barnard Castle testing
his eyesight he said a trip out and so
on um at the time time she said for the
safety of others anyone with Corona
virus symptoms must self-isolate in line
with government gu guidance they should
not leave the house for any reason now
one of another consequence of this of
course is she may well face a fine um in
his statement tonight Mr Blackford has
said that she's referring herself to the
Parliamentary standards commissioner as
well as the police and the police have
told Sky News this is police Scotland
we're aware of the circumstances and
aazing with our colleagues in the Mets
Metropolitan Police Service so clearly a
police investigation is underway there
has been an angry reaction from other
political parties for labor Ian Murray
the SC Shadow Scottish secretary talked
about her astonishing recklessness and
he says she's put passengers rail staff
fellow MPS common staff and many others
at unacceptable risk but clearly as
we've heard as you've read out this
statement from Nicholas sturgeon she is
absolutely livid got another tweet here
from political leader in Scotland
Douglas Ross the Scottish conservative
leader and he has just tweeted that we
are in the middle of a pandemic
traveling hundreds of miles on public
transport having tested positive for
this deadly virus is not a mistake it's
complete disregard for everything we are
fighting against at Margate fer must go
with immediate effect and John ju
imagines that he's not going to be the
only one who's going to call for her to
to go all together because we know as
you say there that Ian Blackford the
snp's leader in Westminster has removed
the whip but other parties wanting more
it's a 400 mile Journey from Glasgow
it's two very long Journeys and as as
Ian Murray's saying all the people she
must have come into contact with on the
train Railway stations in Parliament and
the the speaker and others are very
sensitive to the you go over to
Parliament and it's just full of signs
don't go there don't go there you know
one way traffick in all the corridors
and so on there will be Fury in
Parliament at this and uh I think she's
looking potentially at her th000 fine
and it is conceivable that she may have
to stand down uh if that does happen
because uh MPS will take this very very
seriously